Kurdish led forces have withdrawn from
the northern Syrian town of rasa-lila
apparently in line with the terms of a
deal between the US and Turkey
a convoy of ambulances carrying wounded
civilians and Kurdish fighters was seen
leaving the area on Sunday Ankara wants
to establish a so-called safe zone in
the region and demands Kurdish forces
withdraw completely turkey agreed to
pause fighting in the area last week to
allow their departure that truce is set
to run out on Tuesday and in just a
moment we will speak with andreas NIC a
turkey expert and member of the German
Parliament's Foreign Affairs Committee
but first our next report takes a look
at the contested area for this proposed
safe zone some of the fiercest fighting
against the so-called Islamic state
happened in Syria along Turkey's border
Kurdish fighters helped turn the tide
with the battle for kobani which has
since become one of the main Kurdish
centers for Turkey
that's a provocation it considers
Kurdish forces an existential threat
with regard to the establishment of a
safe zone our aim was for the area to be
cleaned of terrorists as a result of our
president's skilled leadership we got
what we wanted in the negotiations the
area is a fertile plain that once grew
the grain that fed much of Syria about
1.7 million Kurds live here along with
500,000 Syrian Arabs and others but the
area is also home to thousands of is
prisoners guarded by Kurds at several
sites Turkey is reportedly guaranteed
they won't break out though at least one
small-scale prison break has already
happened meanwhile more than 150,000
people have been forced to leave their
homes by the fighting they don't know
what's next I'm very happy about the
ceasefire
I hope all citizens return to the
country but for the time being I won't
return until security is established in
Syria then we'll go back but with
Turkish forces and pro Turkey Syrian
fighters massing in their cities
returning here is on
likely for the Kurds turkey plans to
resettle more than a million refugees
here mainly Syrians originally from
elsewhere in the country
and I am joined now by andreas Nick CDU
member of the Bundestag and Foreign
Affairs Committee and the cdu/csu
parliamentary group spokesperson for
Turkey welcome to the program and thank
you so much for joining us I'd like to
begin by asking you because the German
Foreign Minister Heiko Maas says that
Turkey's operation against those Kurdish
forces in northern Syria is a violation
of international law
given that what action should Germany be
willing to take I think it is clear that
there is no justification under
international law for this military
operation it is not covered I think
under immediate self-defense it is
politically and militarily a risky I
think we have taken this to the UN
Security Council last week we had a
debate here in Parliament we have
initiated some action on the UN on the
EU level with regard to military
procurement issues to Turkey but I think
we should avoid the temptation of just
focusing on punishing Turkey we should
look for solutions to to the to the
region and I think the ceasefire that
has been agreed at least is an initial
first step on which we should build
further but mr. Nick is that enough
because I mean last week President
Erdogan he called the German Foreign
Minister a political amateur era Dewan
doesn't listen to what Berlin has to say
does he well I think there is a specific
political rhetoric in the bilateral
relations which I think emerges to the
to the front every now and then I think
for my experience we will be able to
influence Turkish behavior the the more
and the better if we are seen as also
having a realistic view and an
acknowledgement of Turkey's legitimist
security interests and of Turkey's
contribution with regard to hosting 4
million refugees I think if that's the
starting point you can also have a more
tangible and more
targeted a conversation on what what
should be done and some of that is
better done behind closed doors then buy
a diploma megaphone diplomacy meantime
you know we have the situation on the
ground on the dynamic dramatically
shifting we have Russia's Syria Turkey
really now the key players after US
troops pulled out of northern Syria and
I'm curious to hear how you see the
shifting dynamic and potentially a
changing role for Europe I think really
what has happening has a first and
foremost strengths into the role of the
Assad regime it has strengthened the
role of Russia in Syria the potential
for the EU to contribute to a solution
so far is rather limited I think if the
chance is there to extend the ceasefire
further and give roof was for a
political agreement political solution
on what should be done this would
require at some point not only an
agreement with Russia I would probably
also mandate from the UN Security
Council the you should be willing to
make a constructive contribution to
create a buffer zone that would stop
military violence for more sustained
period but I think that the stakes on
this are high it would require a protic
greement with Syrian government with
Russia and will probably at some point
also require the willingness of EU
countries to commit peace troops to this
region which I think would be a major
challenge but that's wishful thinking
isn't it I mean what if the ceasefire is
not extended because Turkey has only
agreed to a pause in fighting for five
days how concerned are you about what
will happen to the Kurds in the area
when it runs out on Tuesday I think
that's that's something where the top
priority needs to be to extend that
ceasefire I think we should keep all
options open on increasing pressure on
Turkey but on the other end I think any
solution were required to also take into
account a Turkey's legitimate interest
and to do everything we can to maintain
turkeys alliance with the Western with
the West with NATO and with positive
relations with the European Union and
pushing turkey out of that and pushing
Turkey even closer towards Russia or
China is not helpful it will also not
contribute to solving the issue in in
Syria andreas NIC member of the German
Bundestag Foreign Affairs Committee
thank you so much for speaking with us
here on DW thank you